même pas question conne et oui il ya des
lignes hauteur histoire je sens déjà les
tumeurs se forme et personne n'aura des
tumeurs julien le soir ma chérie mon
vendeur est extrêmement motivé tu les
vois un truc magique
quel truc magique
je crois que les choses sont en train de
vie il ya un orage qui va éclater
griffin fais pas ton bébé
j'ai pas peur
comment tu vas entrer ici
qui tu parles
max ernst au lycée on savait plus vers
qui se tourner vous avez sonné à la
bonne porte
ça ne ressemble pas à un cas de maison
hantée comme les autres j'ai jamais vu
une chose pareille
c'est un poltergeist nouveau plus
puissants tout ce que j'ai connu madison
ma chérie on veut tu reviennes chine où
maintenant je suis la maman
le vide dans votre esprit
ils savent déjà ce qui nous fait peur
bernard
et à cette fin il ya des trucs bizarres